people in Massachusetts know me as Ted
Kennedy I'm honored deeply honored
greatly honored represent them in the
United States Senate the greatest public
honor that I could possibly have and in
the the United States the Senate I've
been guided by what I basically brought
there as a as a human being as a as a
person and I still have always believed
that we are created in the images of God
and that the Bible teaches us and in
Matthew about feeding the hungry and
giving to the those that are thirsty and
clothing the naked and visiting the
welcoming the stranger and visiting the
imprisoned and what dr. King said about
walking humbly humbly loving mercy and
doing justice
I think these words can be simple words
but they can also be guiding words and
they've been guiding for me in the
United States Senate where I've tried to
to enhance opportunities for individuals
in the areas of education in health care
and also knocking down walls of
discrimination yeah that have been a
part of our country and our society
written into the Constitution in the
founding fathers and we've fought the
civil war and we've had dr. King and we
had the early 1960s where we began to
knock down walls and discrimination on
the basis of race and gender and
ethnicity in a more recent times on the
issues of disability and and some
progress made in knocking down walls and
discrimination based upon people's
whether they were gay or lesbians as
well we want to try and free ourselves
from the forms of discrimination and
bigotry which exist in our nation though
people are on the receiving end of that
but it is also those that are on the
giving end should free themselves from
that kind of a bigotry and we have it
can't be done just legislatively it has
to be done with the work of communities
and with the works of churches and
that's a continuing challenge
well I have been faced both adversity
and also the the the obscene have had
witnessed great success the times of my
particularly my brothers a sort of
achievement but I I think this this is a
the the sort of the values of our
country of Society of worth fighting for
and I see people who struggle and
struggle very hard to try and make a
difference for the nation which inspires
me and I think there's a real
recognition that with our democracy we
have no guarantee as a nation that we're
going to have future prosperity we have
no guarantee as a nation we're going to
have future security and we have no
guarantee as a nation we're going to
have future hope and opportunity and
progress those values have to be fought
for every single day and I think that's
a responsibility of citizenship I've
been very blessed by the opportunity of
being in the United States Senate and
have an opportunity to fight for those
but I have enormous respect for everyone
that is out there that school teacher
that law enforcement the legal defender
that's trying to that health care worker
trying to give health care trying to
give education trying to bring the
Constitution to people who didn't know
that they had constitutional rights and
liberties so I think it's it's important
to be involved and engaged and I think
there's satisfaction there's
disappointments that come with it but
there's good deal of satisfaction